my pieces yeah what kind of styles is
that are they you know being both from
the chinese school of chess quite
similar kind of styles or very different
um
similar in general
very dynamic their instincts are quite
ambitious they want to take
risks they want to play for the maximum
in every position here we see the nimzo
indian defense um something that i
played against niels grendellis a lot um
last week but uh either way they know
that opening repertoires inside out
these two
so really tense position here
i think it's just going to come down to
who can they get the attack who can get
the momentum on their sides and most
likely that player will be able to win
latinx though is a really tenacious
defender i've seen her defend some
really difficult positions i once played
a seven hour game against her
i was just i thought i was winning after
10 moves and then it took me another 120
moves to win so um yeah she's really
tenacious come on david we know that you
like to play long games
i like to torture myself just as much as
i can
okay meanwhile
very sensible play white taking center
we saw a trade of one side of pawns both
sides castling and now actually not that
common at a move this bishop dropping
back usually there black captures the
white knight with this dark squared
bishop black star squad bishop now on
the side of the board
but this is still relatively known white
has a variety of moves and okay
capturing a pawn and now we might well
see a trade of bishop for night and then
a queen trade
yeah capturing the pawn is a little bit
unusual actually it's much more common
to actually step forward with queen two
squares and uh capturing the pawn
for this reason bishop takes knight and
suddenly white's pawn structure not
ideal
hasn't really been played
yeah um i've actually studied this a
little bit uh mostly from the white side
and i didn't really like it black's
knight now can jump into the middle of
the board and white is temporarily a
pawn up but look at white's pawns on the
left half of the board double pawns on
the sea file and both of white's pawns
on the sea file now attacked by this
black knight it's a double attack black
is guaranteed to win one of those pawns
back and yes white has the bishop pair
but also look at white's dark square
bishop at the bottom of the board at the
bottom of the wood that's not a good
piece
it's just blocked in by all its own
points you know the bar already shifting
towards jooheon yeah um i'm slightly
surprised because when i looked at this
i thought black was just completely fine
but uh maybe the computer knows better
maybe white has a way to get the bishops
working especially that dark squared
bishop
and uh juwen june i would have thought
having rushed into this position having
grabbed a pawn quite early in the game
she must have studied the consequences
here
but uh then again latinx playing really
really quickly yeah after this point i
do find with juwen jinnis that she's
very well versed in the opening up to a
point and then afterwards you can
perhaps go that one move deeper because
whenever i've played her
i have somehow
i've known that slightly a bit more than
her in the opening and i've managed to
get a more comfortable position
so maybe this is something here because
i'm looking at the database and only
five games
and uh not a great score for white
either only one victory and two
victories for black
by the way they look both of them they
look a little bit sleepy i think and
maybe it can be a problem know that you
sometimes you can just mix something in
the opening if you don't feel very well
or just you don't feel yourself a little
bit i remember myself being in china and
facing the same troubles all of us we
we had these problems with jet lag and
maybe they have also some issues yeah
they do start very late at night in
china and they will be finishing today's
action today's games i think in the
early hours of the morning 3 4 a.m so it
will be difficult for them to keep their
energy levels high but uh
meanwhile latinx looking like she's been
playing quickly maybe just still uh in
her opening book having studied this
before but she went it is worrying that
this position even if it's rare that she
doesn't really know which white pawn to
defend or how to
develop white's pieces
it's a really complex position here i
would could easily spend 10 15 minutes
but she went she needs to move quickly
because it's rapid chests and
yeah i'm slightly concerned despite the
evaluation bar that white's position is
maybe the more tricky to handle it's
harder to play white's position black's
next moves are easy black wants to grab
a pawn maybe bring the black bishop out
and occasion jun does bring her bishop
off the first rank connecting the white
rooks but look at that white bishop it's
still stuck staring at its own pawns
and latent j i'm pretty sure she's going
to go back and capture a pawn now with
her knight she's a pawn down temporarily
and
i think it's going to be hard to delay
that tempting move too long
all right well it's exciting to follow a
game between two female players it only
happened once before that we had two
female players in a tournament and we
talked about it quite often ivanka but
what would you say is the state of uh
female chess
um it's getting better yeah i have to
say when you compare it back to the
older times i mean it was really quite
seriously bad and now i see that a lot
more women are getting stronger and
stronger and we're kind of talking about
stronger in depth as well you know
there's quite a few there's a thing
about
five i mean don't quote me on this uh
women who've passed the 2600 level which
is very very strong and of course we
have judith pogar leading the charge you
know she was the lady to break the 2700
mark and uh
especially now with the queen's gambit
and the movie and there's so much chess
being played online i mean we see some
real trailblazers just encouraging women
to play chess i mean we have jennifer
shahade she's just written a book called
chess queen yeah it's not on my kiddo i
can't wait to read it i mean if anyone
wants to go and buy it they should yeah
absolutely and it tells a story about
players just chess players and it is
getting better slowly by slowly the
numbers are just increasing so it is
positive yeah and well anastasia you
mentioned you've also been a commentator
on these uh women's world championship
matches as well um
are you very interested and into it to
to see uh female chess and women in
chess growing as well yes yes of course
i mean it's my favorite topic
and of course i was happy to be present
at the world championship matches myself
and
i think what we have to do we should try
just to bring more and more
girls and women into chess i mean of in
all levels from all countries and
actually i'm trying to do something for
that too i mean fida has a special
project now for refugee camp and we have
a ghost club in kenya and every saturday
also today i'm giving online lessons to
the girls in three schools in kenya in
the kakuma refugee camp this program is
run by was actually uh the idea to start
the program uh was uh by an anastasia
sorokina from feeder but she's a vice
president of feeders so and donna raisin
is so zola another very powerful woman
in chess
manager infide
so she managed management director in
phoenix she actually um supported this
idea and the new project is running now
and uh yeah so i'm really so 150 girls
hopefully i will know how to play chess
i mean and they they know already how to
play chess and uh i hope they will stay
with us and
this is my small contribution and i hope
this program pro program will spread
around the world and we have more and
more girls playing chess what a
fantastic initiative i have to find a
way to sneak into that soon yeah to get
that listen you absolutely do and uh
just to talking about fide it's actually
2022 is their year of the woman in chess
and they will be running a whole sort of
broke program throughout the year to
encourage women to play and also to have
conferences and it will also be in
conjunction with chess24
love it yeah music to my ears and well
uh i did hear another move coming in
after quite a long pause yeah a couple
of moves have happened black did indeed
go and recapture a pawn as we predicted
so now material is level but juwon june
has created a bit of a threat with her
last move with white
so if we just jump in to explain
what both players are thinking about
right now white's last move was to push
a pawn forward and we mentioned this uh
in the last game when in doubt push your
corner pawns forward push those flank
pawns but here there is a direct threat
and it's all about this bishop i
mentioned it earlier on the last move it
was just a blocked in piece just staring
at its own pawns look at this can't get
through this diagonal can't get through
this way either so jew went through by
pushing a pawn forward has initiated the
threat of creating a nasty pin on this
diagonal hitting the black knight and
indirectly the rook behind it and i'm
slightly surprised by this last move i
must admit uh later just pushing her
pawn forward yes she defends her knight
but i felt maybe it was more pertinent
to actually block this white pawn from
stepping forward for example by bringing
the knight to the side of the board
hitting this bishop and just gaining a
bit of time but now after black's pawn
stepped forward i think drew and june
there's nothing else for her to do she
has to improve this bishop
and once this happens maybe a small
advantage for white because suddenly
there is some uncomfortable pressure if
black uh for example just develops a
bishop um struggling to even find a move
then now after bishop takes knight and a
recapture white can start jumping up to
the seventh rank for example um white
can maybe create some annoying threats
against this bishop and it looks roughly
balanced but it's just easier for white
to play also this pawn is a bit weak if
the white knight can jump in later on to
try and attack it and this has happened
the bishop is now pinning this knight
and
along this diagonal some serious
pressure
so maybe issue in june things have gone
in her favor just over the last move or
two
yeah i like the line that you showed for
juwon jun i mean it seems it's difficult
for lei ting jae to actually untangle
her pieces still a lot of excitement on
the board and talking about excitement
and enthusiasm we still want you at home
to be enthusiastic about the game so we
are still asking you to send us your
chess tweets send us your questions your
comments and also your selfies using the
hashtag chesschamps and we will feature
them on the show
yes
all right and
some news about
the donations as well
i hear rumors we have now
passed 10
10 000
in our fundraiser to unicef fantastic
news you guys
again thank you so much to everyone
donating and
keep doing it chess24.com donate to uh
make your donation for unicef
helping the people in and around ukraine
ten thousand dollars yeah that's uh so
it's so beautiful and uh
yeah and i was just i was reminded when
anastasia said that the thing that gives
her hope is actually to look for the
helpers you know when there's this time
of such conflict and you feel such
darkness look for the people helping and
thank you everyone for your very kind
support
and uh yeah day one already yeah
what have
how have you been sort of affected
anastasia what has it been like to see
the neighboring countries of ukraine
taking in refugees of course and also
the the chess community and the way they
have reacted
yes of course i mean chess community we
can see so many things happening these
days so many events so many initiatives
all around you know you can see all
websites all chess players are trying to
contribute and
my facebook is full of this
opportunities and possibilities and
that's great actually i think the whole
chess community united uh let's say to
help um either to children in ukraine or
families or other chess players so and
it's great that it's happening and
actually you feel that you belong to
this community and it's important in
these times to to feel that
yeah so some people who i never met in
my life i mean just because they know me
as a commentator they kind of send the
messages they ask how am i doing my
family they send some help so it's it's
really important just sometimes just
some nice words it's also really
important to hear yeah yes so thanks for
everybody who is now donating during
this stream and during this show it's it
for for the next man for many days
actually you can have this opportunities
and it's great
yeah i agree all right we hear um many
moves coming in here david yeah so black
brought one knight to the side of the
board i mentioned this type of idea a
bit earlier hitting the white light
squared bishop which did retreat and now
black has developed uh latinx has
developed her remaining bishop and there
we go this trade had to happen before
the black rooks went to defend the white
knight so now instead of white having a
bad pawn structure and fractured pawns
isolated pawns on this left side of the
wood black also has weaknesses there and
this last move jumping in with the white
knight i quite like it uh maybe other
options as well for zhu and june i i
really want to see the white rook slide
across one square maybe put some
pressure on the black bishop maybe slide
up to the fifth rank to attack that
black knight on the side of the board
white's knight now is threatening to
maybe jump in attack a rook attacks and
pawns
black has weaknesses and if you compare
the pieces right now white's knight in
the center is much better than black's
knight white's rook in the center on an
open line better than blacks rooks the
bishops it's not clear which is best but
the knights and rooks
favors white uh so zhu and jun in
control for now
and uh latinx that's why she's burning
time on the clock that's why she's been
spending a few minutes over the last few
moves she knows there's pressure
coming into the black position and it's
not clear how to deal with that it's not
even short-term pressure that can be
neutralized over the next two or three
moves um she needs to be accurate for
quite a long time now i feel okay so
it's definitely heating up this game
yeah and uh despite the fact queens are
off despite the fact it is almost the
end game are pretty much the end game
still a draw far far away anything is
still possible here
and okay challenging rooks that's
sensible at least yes i feel we've seen
that a lot today well this is only the
second game we follow but it was a lot
about those rooks in the first game as
well yeah yes i mean now it's a typical
situation when we have the open file to
put the rooks there and to try to
understand who is uh who is the main
piece who is the both white or black so
now actually uh black moved his rook on
the open d file and trying to trade at
least one of the rooks to remove this
pressure
it's like a staring contest the rooks
are just staring at each other neither
side wants to blink because if if black
ever trades the white rook white will
dominate the open file if white ever
trades the rooks black will dominate the
open file so yeah both rooks just
staring at each other neither side
wanting to give away now well actually i
have a question about rooks and open
files will that
basically always be an aim you have in
your games to create an open file and
put your work on it kaya i'm so
impressed with you you're learning
can't fault that at all if you see an
open file put a rook on it basically
yeah it's either that or the seventh
rank for white and the second rank for
black those are the uh kind of ideal
destinations for rooks also if you have
a past pawn put the rook behind it
because rooks are great at supporting
pawns
storming up the board so um
those i think are maybe just the general
outlines for what you want to do with
your rooks i was taught a very um useful
guideline for assessing the value of the
pieces and traditionally when we first
taught the games we kind of taught these
hard and fast rules that the queen is
worth nine points the rook is worth five
points the knight is worth three the
bishop is three and the pawns are worth
one
and
they said well actually
to help you understand that it's all
about what pieces do rather than what
they are think of it like this so when a
rook is on an open line it's actually
worth like five and a half points
when a knight is on a post they can't be
challenged and is really effective can
be up to up to worth like five points
when a bishop is on an open line and a
useful open line well suddenly it can be
you know it can be five points even more
and uh if your bishop is looking at its
own pawn it's not much of a piece
going down and if you think of things
like a sliding scale then it can help
you even come to terms with sacrificing
your own pieces um because this is
something materialists like myself
really struggle with they're like no
it's mine clean i don't want to give it
up
but if you think of the sliding scale it
helps you let go
yeah the trick is to just compare what's
still on the board so you might have
sacrificed loads of pieces but that's
off the board now you forget about that
if the quality of your pieces is much
better than your opponents uh on what in
kind of regarding what remains then uh
often things work out especially if it's
an attack versus defense situation you
might have sacrificed a rook or a piece
but if all of your opponent's extra
pieces on the wrong side of the board
then it doesn't really matter and often
your attack will break through if your
attacking pieces
uh are likely to overwhelm the defenders
so
yeah it's definitely a sliding scale as
your vanco mentions and uh in this
endgame right now it's zhu and june's
turn to think
i'm trying to kind of figure out how
white can break through here how white
can improve the position
it's slightly tempting to do a bit of a
dance with the white knight but i do
like why uh the white knight uh and
where it stands right now i don't like
that white rook in the corner maybe you
could slide it across one square maybe
you could bring the white bishop to a
better square but
lots of choice and that's the one bad
thing about white's position there's a
lot of tempting moves and in rapid chess
you just have to trust your instincts
you just have to choose one of them and
hope for the best sometimes so
what do you ladies think i definitely
think an improving move is uh in order
and i think you know i also was
instinctively thinking of your move the
rook and the corner moving itself to an
open line another idea that i was
thinking of was maybe to introduce the
white king into the game you know step
forward with uh the f porn move up one
square and uh maybe the white king can
think about uh
joining the fun yeah so uh ivanka you'll
move maybe pushing this pawn forward one
square maybe even two squares and uh
next move just entering the action why
not your pieces are better than blacks
at the moment so why not improve your
king as well and the other move we
mentioned there would be to just slide
across one square maybe hinting at
kind of just putting some pressure on
the black knight you're not actually
hitting this bishop right now because
this bishop is defended by the black
knight on the side of the board so you
want to destabilize the defender this
night and for example if black thinks
okay now this rook's moved now i can
trade then white would be happy to just
spend another move with this rook
because as mentioned white has won the
staring contest white occupies this
whole open file and yeah right now this
causes some problems for black for
example even if black gets time to kick
away this white knight white's knight
does have opportunities at some point to
for example even jump forward into the
position to attack this isolated pawn
and uh yeah it's really nice to continue
this variation we see if if black moves
his rook or d8 what can happen in this
case yeah
nice so trying to maybe create some type
of pin but you always have to make sure
your pieces are defended and this rook
is loose so anastasia yes i think knight
f6 can come nice the white knight jumps
out with a check
that's why we say look at checks in
every position first because checks gain
time and they can be super effective and
after this night sacrifices itself we
see this rook undefended and white
definitely wins the staring contest this
time rook takes rook check wins a piece
so this is
a few moves down the line but this is
the type of thing that can happen if
white is energetic and if black doesn't
defend correctly so
the more i look at it the more i just
like this move
trying to persuade black to um
trade rooks on white's terms but also
creating the threat of trying to hit
this black knight on the side of the
board this night's actually on an
outpost but we do say that knights on
the room are dim so why not try and go
for it why not try and attack it and
using the white rook but then again
ivanka's move makes a lot of sense you
could maybe argue for moving this bishop
just kind of planting it on a good
square trying to force black to make
concessions loosen up his position
uh joe and june either way this is not
the type of position where you have to
spend six minutes i probably would simon
being a hypocrite but uh yeah rapid
chess i think not six minutes wow six
minutes six minutes is too too much you
could play three games already yes yeah
play a couple of blitz
i also i have to mention one thing um so
i played you engine uh twice first time
i won
in a kind of convincing way second time
actually one on time
and
it was somehow she just went into some
kind of trance and she was considering
all her all her options and okay
admittedly you know i was slightly
better very slightly better and she was
kind of adjusting to that change and
then
this was a classical game and this was a
classical game she just froze yeah you
wanna go wait a minute do you have 2-0
score against the world champion yeah
really why yeah no i mean i mean i've
only played two games but still
something to be proud of
but it was before she became world
champion
but okay anyway she's still a very
strong player but what i noticed is that
she just froze that was my kind of
observation and uh
the clock i was i felt really terrible
actually just saying you're lost on time
it rarely happens in long games these
days
because you do gain a bit of time after
every move but sometimes you just forget
uh players do forget about the clock and
i've always thought it's interesting
actually the world champions magnus
castle and juwon june they're both 31
years old they're both the same age ah
so yeah both at the peak of their palace
and she went june though shaking her
head maybe she's just struggling to find
a breakthrough
um often rapping chess at least from my
experience at some point
every player hates their position uh you
might get a game where things aren't
going well you just have to
kind of trust your instincts and if
there's no direct threat white can never
be worse in this position if you want to
even make a draw at some point you just
trade all the rooks off and it's fine so
worse comes the worst just improve a
piece just stop calculating
and uh
i've noticed uh joe and june in
particular but chinese players in
general are very very very good at
calculating sometimes they rely on it
too much sometimes uh it's nice to just
take a step back and just generalize
about the position do what we do just
kind of just kind of okay this piece
belongs here this piece is better than
that piece just the kind of going back
to basics and
i mean i forget to do that sometimes in
my games it's so easy to get carried
away in the position but
it really helps
especially with decision making yeah
eight and a half minutes now duel engine
luxury yeah and uh david actually
mentioned the word improvement and i
just wanted to
put a question to both nastia and david
and ask them see these questions there
comes to move after almost nine minutes
and it is an improving rook move that we
did discuss good move yeah and uh they
ask is it very important to study the
openings and can they help you improve
your rating
yeah what i can say i mean all my life i
was struggling in the openings
you know and actually um i i was
following this idea that you have to
survive in the opening and then here we
go finally the middle game and to hear
the fun stars so let's say i cannot say
that i was a really good student so
probably we should ask this question
then
i think i heard actually actually the
exact same from david surviving the
opening
exactly
yeah i'm not sure i'm the best student
when it comes to openings uh i have gone
through phases in my life where i've
studied openings a lot and it does pay
off from time to time but it's not the
only thing you should study i think
that's the the main point um opening is
there a means to an end uh very rarely
do you win directly out of the opening
occasionally if your opponent makes
mistakes but it's just to give you your
type of position or position you enjoy
playing so um it's exactly what
anastasia has just said uh for example
in my match against neil's
granddaughters recently i only studied
openings in order to survive and get
through to the middle game in positions
that i enjoyed
um it wasn't about winning out of the
opening it wasn't about getting an
advantage or even an equal position it
was just about getting positions that i
like to play
so i just had a thought so okay if you
if you are
dedicated to the opening so you should
study the opening how to win better end
games
yeah don't worry about defensive ones
and then how to win attacks so those are
the three things and there you go you
got a nice little road of improvement if
you don't want to study openings you've
got to study defending bad positions
[Laughter]
transfer attacks
yes your creativity
creativity and okay yeah you're set okay
so i guess it's up to sort of uh finding
your style then yeah basically study
everything yes
yeah just actually chess is just a fun
game to play you know even if you don't
know the openings try to follow the
principles of the openings like take
care of your center centralize your
pieces do castling you know those
principles try to survive and then let's
say move on and uh
yeah so but still david plays in a
different level and we should still he's
very modest person he knows openings i
think still in the very decent level
yeah and i guess you know to get from
one level to another level for example
studying openings will be a good way to
to really improve yeah i mean it's it's
one of the easiest things to study but
it it is very very effective um
especially with the white side um you
can put immediate pressure on your
opponents so um i recommend studying
those things for sure but yeah just
don't make don't let it be at expense of
the other parts of your game and okay
meanwhile latency attacking the white
knight kicking it away from the sentence
something similar to what we showed the
white knight did jump in to the black
position actually attacking a pawn now
black's pawn on the c5 square uh
attacked by the white knight
and it's not so easy to defend there's
also a potential possible threat of
white's rook coming up next to the black
knight and uh okay later in shape really
has to calculate well both players have
to start calculating now it is becoming
more tactical this end game
uh yeah what do we think wow it's
interesting actually first of all the
knight went too far away yes so you have
to make sure that you don't lose it
anywhere if you if you move your piece
too far
try to make sure it will not be trapped
yeah so now rook seat is a very concrete
move right the last move of black and
i don't know i started to calculate some
ideas with knight c5 or something like
this all these uh are in the air uh
taking the spawn but i'm not sure
what's going on at the moment
yeah it's really interesting because
white's kind of semi threat as we
mentioned to bring the white rook up
okay has actually happened on the board
so we don't need to show it but this is
going to be met by black's bishop moving
the black knight can't move because then
the black bishop would fall to the white
rook so black's bishop has to
counter-attack by hitting the white rook
and there's two directions you can go in
you can either go to the side of the
wood hit the white rook and the bishop
behind it there we go it's happened or
you could have gone the other direction
but we do see a trade bishop for night
and who's this gonna favor
look at this white's knight is deep in
black's camp black's bishop is a bit of
an intruder here in white's uh white
camp as well
both pieces
out on a limb and
i'm expecting white's rook to shift up
to one square i'm not sure which square
do you step up one square hit the black
bishop do you step up the whole way to
the sixth rank
yes it's definitely heating up now at
the clock times as well in case it's
stepped up to attack the bishop but uh
nasty you're
[Laughter]
yeah sorry um well your idea of the
white knight getting trapped is
certainly in the air actually it can't
get trapped right now
because of your again your ideas of
knight takes pawn jack yes actually it
was it was discussed long time ago yes
this small trick but now black cannot
move his rook forward in order to
threaten the night because because of
the same trick knight takes the pawn
with the check wow
so
um at the same time rook if there is
this rook will take the bishop then the
knight will be hanging right at the same
time yeah so maybe we can just show this
uh because right now there's
kind of a threat but it's kind of not a
threat as you mentioned um it looks like
you're eyeing up this bishop but if
black just moves uh for example then if
you take this bishop the white knight
falls and all pawns here are level and
uh this one would just be an equal
position the one thing i want to see
white do though at some point in this
type of position or even if we rewind a
couple of moves i want to see white
create some space for this king because
you've got to be really careful for
example in that variation after rook
takes bishop rotates knight there is a
threat of checkmate and again this type
of idea will exist in lots of different
types of positions until you pick up
harry or gary one of these hog pawns and
you create some space
for the white monarch so yeah right now
really really tense position i'm
expecting maybe this bishop to just move
because you don't you can't keep it
there forever but then again white is
attacking this pawn so maybe juwen june
would temporarily go upon up
one idea maybe is for example i'm
looking for squares for this bishop you
could go back this way and if you
retreat this way now you could make use
of the fact that this is a pin by
bringing your bishop back and still some
pressure okay she has done this latinjay
um so white will have won a pawn but
this knight is completely pinned and uh
some pressure on it right now attacked
by blackstroke and by black's bishop and
the bar is reacting to that move yeah i
thought it was the most natural but it's
such a difficult position dating shay we
mentioned she was coming under pressure
and this has happened white has won a
pawn um and i'm expecting if the bishop
does drop back which it has just done
then now before it's too late you need
to give your king some breathing space
push one of these three pawns in front
of your king i'm not sure which one is
best but you have to just give your king
some breathing space just in case things
go wrong all right well women world
champion jewen jun the uh the other
world champion magnus carlsen is the bar
all the way over to his side in his game
against hari krishna dingley ren the
other chinese player in this tournament
we have three the bar also all the way
over to his side in the game against
eric hansen
and this one will it end up with a
winner
it's still in the balance black is
fighting for the draw though that is uh
the one thing unless we see a big big
blunder i don't think we'll see latinx
win this game um juwen june
now creating some space for her king
i think if things go wrong for white at
the very least you should just be able
to trade off everything and go for a
draw
um i like this last move for white and
finally finally
we're waiting for it to happen and
as both players tick down now uh drew
and june to three minutes later five
minutes i still think we'll see some
surprises
uh it's still not the type of position
that's easy to hold for black it's still
not the type of position that's easy to
convert for white so
and uh right now less than 90 minutes to
go in the auction for david's lucky
chest i'm going to call it lucky chest
high now the current bid 300 is
fantastic but you still have
uh what is it 88 minutes to make your
bid for this chest tie so head into uh
cct auction uh is that correct
cctauction.com yes actually i'm
wondering if it's going to be the most
expensive chest i ever
going to be in the guinness world record
book you're used to that david well yeah
it's been a while since i've been a
record holder
no either way thank you everyone at home
and uh yeah those in ukraine definitely
appreciate it
absolutely generously yeah
all right well this game i mean both
players are down to very little time on
the clock and
i understand on you guys it's tense it
must be hard to play this position yeah
and suddenly black's going for mass
trades gonna exchange everything off are
you surprised about that anastasia
because now lots of trades black's going
for white's extra porn white to point up
but white's going to win a pawn back in
the process it's going to be quite
one-sided now as in
in terms of winning chances playing for
two results there's no risk at all for
white
it's going to be hard to win this one
but
rook and games they're tricky at the
best of times no matter what the level
there's always going to be chances when
you are a pawn up
yeah i agree with that and it's also a c
pawn that white has as extra extra
material and that's a pawn that's
actually easier for the white king to
assist should it need to be pushed
and uh
i wasn't sure about uh jew engine's last
move i wasn't sure whether it was worth
pushing the central pawn up one square
just to kind of control black spawns a
little bit more or should she be going
for this pawn push i think she's just
following the rule that we talked about
the last game when in doubt just push
harry the h
simon williams watching at home shout
out to simon uh yeah he's going to be
watching this just
with glee yeah
yeah i guess it's quite useful in rook
end games as well to push pawns as far
down the board as possible just because
if it comes down to a pawn race your
pawns are ready to promote later in the
game also if you stop your opponent's
pawns from advancing you could fix a
weakness for example the pawn in front
of the black king now cannot move two
squares that pawn might be uh it might
cause the black king to be tied down
okay black now gaining the space yes
actually you were right when you
proposed the movie four i think because
now black gained some space yes by
pushing this yes i i wasn't sure whether
you needed to be like super precise to
maximize any winning chances i mean
because after all the white king
can still run towards the santa i mean
this is a big idea in this position to
baby give up the pawns that you have
on the right side and just bank
everything on that past sea pawn but it
has to be well timed you can't just run
with a king immediately yeah the problem
is for this white king that you're cut
off at the moment um you're cut off on
the second rank so you can't as ivanka
mentions you kind of want to just make a
mad dash for it and
help support your sea pawn forward um
this is your ex report after all and
they say pass pawns are there to be
pushed but it's hard to do that the
black rook doing a good job of cutting
the king so maybe you want to use this
route as well you could kind of come
from the side and centralize yourself
you need to get your king into the
action you can't play without that piece
kings are so important in the end game
but then again
zhu and jun she stepped back with her
rook now she has to deal with threats of
attacks against her pawns this pawn is a
bit weak and the white rook stuck in
front of this pawn now
if you could kind of flick the two rooks
around if you could change the order
white would be winning rooks belong
behind passports white's rook is
currently trapped in front of its own
pawn so if we catch up with the current
game position both sides improving their
kings now
to me it's gonna be very hard to win
this game white's rook is just stuck in
front of his own pawn it's purely
defensive passive uh black's rook doing
a good job now of eyeing up this pawn
eyeing up the pawn here and uh yeah i
think latinja has done everything right
so far to try and draw this game but
still a long way to go still a lot of
pawns still on the board
well hans niemann a great win for him in
round two here against david anton so
three points four hans niemann that is a
great start for the american
all right and this one while david's
saying now
probably will be hard to win it if
anyone's going to win it is that white
it's only white with winning chances
like fighting for the draw okay
well she doesn't have that much time
either jew engine only two and a half
minutes left on the clock to find that
win
she's sped up though she has sped up and
does david will tell you this is the
kind of position that he excels in
because he can just make as many
non-moves as he can
so you know watch out for that white
king it can make i don't know 10 moves
without making any
changes to the actual position
and uh you know build up time on the
clock
yeah um the reason i like these
positions these types of positions
because i have commitment issues as you
mentioned ivanka i don't want to commit
the white king i don't want to commit
the pawns you just wait and wait and
wait until your opponent makes a mistake
and uh here i think winning this game
will require a mistake from black but
mistakes might happen for example if
black puts the king on the wrong square
if black retreats the king then white
could push a pawn up in the center of
the board and fix that black king uh in
kind of into passivity forever
if the black rook ever kind of
goes away and allows the white rook to
get active again maybe there's some
winning chances for white
so you just have to wait and be patient
and uh shuen jun she's maybe known for
more dynamic chess maybe more attacking
chess in general but i've seen her win
some really
kind of technical end games like this
including more championship matches so
um yeah i
was still
reluctant to call this a draw
despite the fact that it's very very
hard for white to push any pawns forward
without creating weaknesses so
okay
latin j thinking right now
i would just pass here for black i would
maybe just move the rook down one square
the black rook i want to keep it behind
white extra pawn on the c file
and if you just drop it down you could
threaten some checks you could just
swing across and annoy white from white
from behind attacking loads of pawns
um yeah you don't want to commit
anything here with black
you just want to sit and uh
i think both players are waiting here
white's waiting for mistake black's just
waiting and saying you can't make
progress
and what do we think odds are most
likely a draw but yeah i mean activity
of the pieces is so important in the
ending and especially the king's
activity right so if white will manage
to activate his king at a certain point
something what you mentioned david like
maybe by pushing this central pawn and
then moving
you know pushing this kink towards the
edge of the board maybe he has um i mean
white will have some chances here um but
i was surprised that uh
she went for this position so quickly so
surely like she was so confident to play
that um made few moves uh very quickly
so it's like probably she feels quite
confident
about this rook ending yeah maybe she
studied something similar before and
just to show the point as well you
mentioned that white's king would love
to get active but if it goes too far
away then the black rope might start
coming behind and attacking the pawns on
this side of the board and uh again if
you give a check you would love to kick
the black king back because now white's
king can get active and maybe start
whoops sorry not go back uh might start
marching forward but the problem is
black's king would then be the active
one and black's king would step forward
and now the black king completely shuts
off the white king's progress so okay
this is patient stuff from both players
as i advocated just make slow moves just
one step forward maybe then white goes
behind to try and just pretend that you
can uh kind of swing across and uh maybe
start marching this guy forward
eventually but
either way there's also a nice nice idea
maybe to run with the king
and uh use the rook as a defender
okay yeah as a defender of the pawns on
the right for example if black weights
you could move across and now if the
rook slides across yeah as you mentioned
ivanka you bring the white rook across
and use it as a defender of the pawns
the only thing you've got to be careful
of i guess is that
you get shut out of the game
and this white rook now is not coming
back but then again at least you have
free uh kind of this pawn is free to
roam so free to run up the board yeah
okay interesting it's still really
complicated despite the evaluation bar
not being excited at all in this
position let's go back to the players
can leading shea defenders and okay
she's down to one minute as well
hey on the defensive side that's not
good
um your nerves will be jangling a bit
later on
especially if you lose control if white
does something you don't expect
okay she does commit with one of the
pawns
i would have been hesitant to do this
because now white's rook can step up and
the black king is forced back
okay she must have calculated this one
and she must be gambling that both kings
will now be passive
okay and really commit to that decision
yeah definitely commit or um
i don't know that pawn could be a
weakness could be a strength like you
say but david i do have a question from
ew and it's uh pertains to your tie
he they ask will david sign the back of
the tie
actually
you ask that but uh
it's already signed
you you thought took a few moves ahead
right exactly i planned ahead i forced
all that
the current bid for your tire is four
hundred dollars
an incredible amount of generosity from
everyone so thank you yeah i feel like i
should do more than just sign it now
[Laughter]
fantastic your generosity out there in
the world to our viewers is fantastic so
thank you so much and we're gonna keep
this fundraiser going for eight
days and we have uh content coming up
for you to uh be able to donate auctions
and many things coming up many moves
coming out as well yep so white's rook
did indeed go up to the top of the board
so white pawn can actually start running
this white sea pawn um it might not get
too far but meanwhile black is just
harassing the white king now giving some
checks attacking some pawns
white's king not being able to join the
action join the fun the more i look at
it the more i think actually latinjay's
decision to just block the pawns maybe
will be justified
it's gonna be hard for white to break
through now
uh there's nothing else to do at some
point you have to start pushing your
white sea pawn but then the black rook
has even more scope to give checks
it's going to be really hard for the
white king and therefore hard for zhu
engineering to win and
also gio engine is going to be thinking
about does she
go all in roll the dice and run with the
keying towards the center of the board
and
bank on her pawn being the faster one or
is she just going to play a safe and
maybe just
accept that it's a draw yeah that's a
good point because any winning attempt
here involving the white king making a
run for it comes with loads of risk
if you sacrifice all of white's pawns on
the right side of the board maybe white
will be even slow in that race and you
mentioned the sea pawn ivanka being
maybe easier to support for the white
king than the a pawn but it's also
easier for the black king to stop it
than if the pawn were maybe a couple of
ranks the other way
uh a couple of files sorry the other way
so yeah it's
difficult here and she was just weighing
up the risk zhu in june of running with
the white king towards that pawn
she says no just stepping back with the
white rook
and i have a feeling that uh
jew engine will probably admit that it's
just a draw i don't think she's gonna
take the risk and
go with a mad
king dash towards the center of the
board i have to say i once commented in
a tournament where there were very
similar end games like this on the board
and i have to say like 50 of the players
actually went all in and they went crazy
with the king and they lost oh and i
remember watching i was like
unbelievable
they lost it i mean especially when the
clock is ticking down
it's uh
okay she's going for it she's going for
it not settling for any draw anytime
soon and okay she's offering a trade of
pawns because now if black captures this
pawn that has just moved then white's
king gets slightly more active i don't
think it changes too much i think black
should actually capture that pawn and
then start maybe giving giving some
checks with the black rook to force the
white king back
but okay it's good to see she's trying
but yeah i mean it shows the fighting
spirit of both girls in general women
they like to play until the end you know
and if they think they have chances they
will try to push
yeah they're both very ambitious players
i mean they always i mean that's why
they've risen to the top of uh world
chess right so actually you have to be
so ambitious right in order to improve
in chess all the time you have to try to
play every position until the end we
have a great example world champion
magnus carlsen as well who is
who can how do you say this knees the
water from the stone
is it correct yeah i heard that term
yeah yes so so i think it's a very
important quality
yeah well that's definitely what we saw
in the world championship match right
when magnus won game six
the the longest game in world
championship history he was definitely
squeezing
in that game yeah and zhu and jun she's
trying to squeeze but leytin shea is not
letting her squeeze water from the stone
black gave a check with the rook forcing
the white king back and now look at the
black rook attacking two pawns at the
same time
letting shades okay she has just won her
pawn back it's now level
pawns but more importantly the pawns are
disappearing and this one is going to
fizzle out to a draw we could see a
scenario where both rooks start going
for the enemy pawns everything just gets
traded off
and uh rook against rook it's just going
to be a draw so
yeah juan june you can tell body
language as well she knows her chance
has gone but
i don't think she had any winning
chances because latin j just defended so
well this rook in game
really tenacious defense
yeah you can almost see the
disappointment on her body language um
will it be a
draw offer or will they repeat some
moves
no i think they will repeat
yeah here we go move repetition coming
in and we're going to see a draw between
the two female players in this
tournament